-We are in the doom box.
Our next three songs
will decide tonight's champion.
It's time for
Slay It, Don't Spray It.
-♪ You better know the words
or you'll get sprayed ♪
-Alright, here's how this works.
On your turn,
you're going to have to sing
a well-known song karaoke style.
You'll have the lyrics
in front of you,
but when the music drops out,
you're going to have to
finish the line from memory.
If you don't get
the lyrics exactly right,
those microphones will spray you
and your partner
in the face with water.
But if you can slay it and sing
all the words perfectly,
then your opponents
get drenched instead.
Each song is worth
50,000 points.
All right, Kesha,
Renee, your team is up first.
Let's see what song you get.
♪♪
-"9 to 5," Dolly Parton.
-Who's going to do this one?
-I'll do it.
-All right. Here we go.
-Whoo, this is a hard one,
y'all!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Get ready, get ready,
get ready, get ready!
♪ It's enough to drive you crazy
if you let it ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Cheers ]
-Sorry. No, I'm sorry.
-That felt good.
-Sorry, you got a little wet.
-A little bit.
-I'm sorry about that.
-I'm wet, man.
-I apologize.
-Hey, man.
You're super wet, man.
-Let's see that
in slow motion, please.
[ Laughter ]
[ Slow motion bleeping ]
50,000 points for your team.
-Oh, my God.
-That is how you do it.
-Yes!
-Nailed it. All right, Big Boi,
Kenan, it is your turn.
-Let's see what song you get.
♪♪
-You got "Happy" by Pharrell.
-Oh, [bleep] yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Which one of you knows
"Happy" by Pharrell?
Ooh, wow.
-Kenan, man, you got this.
-He's actually doing it
with a serious face.
-Right now. I know this song.
-There we go.
-With my wet face.
-Here comes the music.
Go for it, Kenan.
♪♪
♪ If you feel like
that's what you wanna do ♪
-Yeah!
[ Kesha and Renee scream ]
-I started dancing
and I forgot!
-Oh, my -- They pushed
right back to the wall.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Slow-motion screaming ]
[ Laughter ]
-So sorry.
-He's not sorry at all.
You got it right in the face.
[ Laughter ]
-That's why I wore my hair
in a ponytail.
-That is 50,000 points for you.
-Yes, it is.
-Well done, Kenan.
-We just won.
-We just won. We just won.
-We won the whole thing.
Congratulations.
Congratulations, man.
-Here we go.
It is time for the final round.
We're going to make things
a little more interesting.
Watch your heads because we got
the big microphones coming in.
-Somebody better call Rihanna,
'cause y'all are going to need
an umbrella.
-Now, all four of you are going
to take turns singing,
so pay attention to your screen.
You'll switch off line by line
when the music stops.
And this round
is worth 200,000 points.
-So whoever wins this
wins the whole thing.
Let's see what
our final song is.
♪♪
"September"
by Earth, Wind, And Fire.
[ Both vocalizing ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Vocalizing continues ]
-Okay, here we go.
Thank goodness
I'm not in the booth.
All right, Kesha,
you're going to start us off.
Here we go.
♪♪
Kesha, you first.
Come on, Kesha.
-You got it. You got it.
-One, two, three.
-Kenan!
-Renee!
-Big Boi!
-Next up, Kesha, get ready.
-Okay, okay.
-Kenan, you're next.
-Renee, you're next.
-Big Boi, get ready.
-♪ Whoa ♪
-Kesha.
-Kenan.
-♪ Dancing in the light of day ♪
[ Buzzer ]
-Agh!
[ Laughter ]
Hey, hey!
-[ Laughs ]
You knew that wasn't it.
You knew.
You knew that wasn't even close.
-I didn't have it.
[ Slow-motion shouting ]
[ Laughter ]
-Come on out!
You are the champions.
You won!
-Man, we won the game.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[Bleep]
-[ Shouts ]
You get a golden boombox.
Let me give it you.
Here. Here you go.
-[ Grumbling ]
-Congratulations, the champs!
-Oh!